A rising tide of Islamist militancy in Africa
is a growing threat to the US and Europe.
There is a dangerous misconception that African
militant groups are too locally focused or
weak to pose a real danger.
Africa is the next front for the Salafi-jihadi
movement, a global ideological movement that
includes ISIS and al Qaeda.
African Salafi-jihadi groups provide a local
base and source of resilience for these organizations.
They are gaining strength not because of ideological
resonance, but because the spread of insurgencies
and conflict creates opportunities to insinuate
themselves in communities.
The Trump administration is trying to do more
against these groups with increased raids
and drone strikes in places like Somalia.
But it still has failed to recognize the link
between local conflicts and grievances and
the Salafi-jihadi movement.
These local issues—conflict and poor governance—feel
remote and irrelevant to Americans.
And the task of resolving them, from Nigeria
to Mali to Libya to Somalia, is large.
But Americans must understand that addressing
these challenges now is far cheaper than fighting
yet another war.
What's your take on American policy in Africa?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.